what is one thing that you'd want people
to know about the border that the media
won't tell you what's something we don't
know is like a regular citizen
unfortunately there's so many things but
I mean realistically the
the greatest thing that I think the
public needs to understand
is that it's not just about illegal
migration it's not just kids or families
it's the the greater threat that's posed
by these criminal organizations I mean
when you've got a multi-billion dollar
organization that controls the border
that can move people Commodities freely
that's problematic yeah
um it feels very problematic as like a
someone who's just in a place like yeah
it'd be scary if I left like a window
open at night and I knew that people
outside of the window had a very strong
business and wanted things to come in my
window oh absolutely and they're going
to do whatever it takes to get it done
wow um these aren't uh they're not doing
it for altruistic you know good-natured
purposes they're doing it for the Mighty
Dollar do you have uh do you ever have
compromised uh employees on your side
yeah unfortunately it happens
um the reality is again I think it'd be
hard to do so I'll give you two
scenarios the reality is uh the money is
there
um and so people that are recruited in
the border patrol and we've got people
from all over the United States
um some some of which such as myself who
were born and raised near the border so
and you work in the Border environment
you've got folks that come from Back
East uh Michigan places like that that
have never experienced the border and
they get down there and it's just this
culture shock and uh we uh
in in Border Patrol parlance we used to
call it a a 10-4 scenario which is a
police code for everything's okay 10-4
but you call it a 10-4 because here I am
I'm a four walking into a bar and this
10 comes up and starts hitting on me um
well what she's doing is she's working
you to corrupt you and so we've seen a
couple
circumstances where that's happened so
the reality is is there corruption or
can corruption happen yes right but the
it's easier in Mexico than it is in the
U.S uh simply because of you know the
pay is different it's also culturally
accepted in Mexico
um one of the sayings down there's plumo
Plata
um
give me uh give me a silver or give me a
bullet some silver being money right and
so you know Mexico's been changing
working towards getting away from
corruption but it's still a reality of
the environment down there yeah
um wow it's a real dark force over there
you're not really just up against the
people that are coming across uh you're
up against the possibility of those
people
um not just being like people fleeing
for a better life you're up against the
possibility of those people being
criminals
um and then you're up against the the
the the the both of those being
fortified and supported by by billions
of dollars by by a really a strong
running business by Dirty Money but yes
absolutely wow yeah you know the other
aspect too is we've had uh cartels pay
people
to join the board of clean record get
them to join the border patrol and then
and then use them for information
um enforcement routes and stuff like
that to pass Goods so it's an everyday
threat
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one